- You have an awesome
connection with your fans.
- Yes!
- And I actually love that about you
and I think that's why you're successful
and, what is like maybe, your most fun,
or coolest kind of fan encounter?
- I mean there's so many,
I really do genuinely
love my fans so much,
I mean, when you come from,
- It shows.
the digital space, you really understand
that there's no record label,
there's no one that started,
except for people just
supporting you online.
So those supporters are really responsible
for a lot of what I have
and I have so much love for them.
But one of the most meaningful stories
I think, you know, earlier this year
when I came out online,
I remember I was really scared
and it was before I had a trip to India.
And, you know, Indian
culture is quite taboo
when it comes to sexuality
and I was so stressed going
to India and I was like,
"Oh, what are people gonna think?
"I don't know."
And I had a meet and greet
and I met with two hundred
fans, and honestly,
I'd say about a hundred fans came up to me
to my face, during that meet and greet
and for me that was so powerful because
one, I know how hard that is.
And I was like, "Wow, me being myself
"did something for you."
- And you inspired them
to be confident enough to say that.
- And what better legacy, you know?
- That's the coolest.
- And so, that was very cool.
(applause)
- Thank you.